A quick warning, there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of the show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
一个简短的警告，今天的节目中包含未经消音的脏话。如果您更喜欢消音版本，可以访问我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org。
People are complicated. That's my radical message for you today, America. People contain their opposites. I personally, for example, can be a good listener, helpful to others, and also exactly the opposite, totally inattentive. And I don't think I'm very unusual when it comes to all that.
人是复杂的。这就是我今天向美国传达的激进信息。人们内心包含着对立面。例如，就我个人而言，我既可以是一个善于倾听、乐于助人的人，也可以完全相反，是个心不在焉的人。对于这一切，我不认为自己有什么特别之处。
In fact, something I always find kind of annoying is when people say, I'm a good person. Oh, yeah, sure, I did whatever. But, you know, I'm a good person. Blah, blah, blah, but he's a good person. Really?
事实上，我总觉得人们说“我是一个好人”时，让人有些反感。哦，是啊，当然，我做过什么什么，但是，你知道，我是一个好人。吧啦吧啦，但他是个好人。真的吗？
I think that says nothing real about you at all. Because most of us are a mix of good and bad, right? We have thoughtful days, and we have annoyed days. To me, somebody who says, "I'm a good person," is somebody who is not taking a very serious look at everything they do, who they look out for and who they neglect, and all the things they could be doing for others if they really were so good.
我认为这根本不能说明你有什么真实的情况。因为我们大多数人都是好与坏的混合体，对吧？我们有深思熟虑的日子，也有心烦意乱的日子。对我来说，一个说“我是一个好人”的人，是一个没有非常认真地审视自己所作所为的人，他们不知道自己关照了谁，忽视了谁，如果他们真的那么好，他们本可以为别人做些什么。
To be clear, there are good people out there. There are genuinely generous, good people. I've met them. We've all met them. But in my experience, one thing they have in common is that they know better than to sum it up with the words, "I'm a good person." Because one of the things that makes them good people is that they know that they contain kindness and awfulness, light and dark, depending on the moment.
需要明确的是，世界上确实有好的。有真正慷慨、善良的人。我见过他们。我们大家都见过他们。但根据我的经验，他们有一个共同点，那就是他们知道不要用“我是一个好人”这几个字来概括自己。因为让他们成为好人的原因之一是，他们知道自己内心既有善良也有丑陋，有光明也有黑暗，这取决于具体的时刻。
Years ago, I had the unusual experience of having dinner with Tom Hanks. And one thing I loved about Tom Hanks is how annoyed he was at this reputation he has in the press of being such a nice guy. Journalists write entire articles about him, and that is the angle-- he's such a nice guy. If I had to sum up his attitude towards this, at least expressed in that one conversation, he said basically, I'm normal.
多年前，我有过一次与汤姆·汉克斯共进晚餐的不寻常经历。汤姆·汉克斯让我喜欢的一点是，他对自己作为“好人”的媒体形象感到多么厌烦。记者们写了一整篇关于他的文章，角度就是——他是个好人。如果我必须总结他对此的态度，至少在那次谈话中，他基本上说的是，我很正常。
And so when I meet a stranger, when I'm in a work situation, I do what normal people do, and I try to act pleasant. And then there were other times in my life when, like anyone normal, I get irritated. I get angry. I'm not so nice. People contain their opposites, which brings me to Jerry Springer, the king of trash TV.
所以，当我遇到陌生人，当我在工作场合时，我会像正常人一样做，我会努力表现得和善。但生活中也有其他时候，像任何正常人一样，我会感到烦躁，我会生气，我并不那么友善。人们包含着他们的对立面，这让我想到了杰瑞·斯普林格，垃圾电视之王。
When he died two weeks ago, it made me think of the story that we did about him years ago, about this whole other side of him than the one most of us think of. And that's his political career. This was early in his life. He was deeply idealistic in a kind of John F. Kennedy, Bobby Kennedy kind of way. And I actually found this very moving. Springer had a hard time walking away from that part of himself.
他两周前去世时，让我想起了我们多年前做过的关于他的故事，关于他完全不同于我们大多数人印象中的另一面。那就是他的政治生涯。那是在他年轻的时候。他有一种约翰·肯尼迪、鲍比·肯尼迪式的深刻理想主义。我实际上觉得这非常感人。斯普林格很难摆脱那一部分的自己。
That part of him, as you'll hear when you hear the story, stayed very much alive inside the trash TV host as the years passed. So today on our show, what we're going to do is we're going to play you that story, which we first broadcast 20 years ago when Springer was still in the prime of his daytime TV career. This was part of an episode that we called back then "Leaving the Fold," all about people leaving some world that they had once inhabited, leaving some part of themselves behind, and how they missed it once they were gone.
正如你稍后听到的故事，随着岁月的流逝，他内心的那一部分在垃圾电视节目主持人的身体里依然活跃。所以今天在我们的节目中，我们要播放那个故事，它是20年前首次播出的，当时斯普林格的日间电视事业正处于巅峰。这是我们当时称之为“离开群体”的一集的一部分，讲的是人们离开曾经居住的某种世界，抛下自己的一部分，以及他们离开后是如何怀念它的。
So we have that. We have some other stuff. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
所以我们有这些。我们还有其他一些内容。这里是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, He Contains Multitudes. So let's start today with our story about Jerry Springer, first broadcast in 2004. One of our producers at the time, Alex Blumberg, grew up in the city where Springer was mayor, and he put the story together.
第一幕，他包含着众生。那么今天让我们从关于杰瑞·斯普林格的故事开始，该故事首播于2004年。当时我们的一位制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格在斯普林格担任市长的城市长大，他整理了这个故事。
Jerry Springer arrived in Cincinnati in 1969, fresh out of law school with a job at a downtown firm. And in just six months, he announced he was running for Congress against the conservative incumbent. He was 25. He had no experience. Nobody had ever heard of him.
杰瑞·斯普林格于1969年来到辛辛那提，刚从法学院毕业，在市中心的一家律师事务所工作。仅仅六个月后，他就宣布竞选国会议员，挑战现任的保守派议员。他当时25岁，毫无经验，没人听说过他。
But he was against the war in Vietnam, and he supported civil rights. And here's the thing you might not guess. He was fantastic. Patricia Garry and Jene Galvin are both Cincinnati political veterans. Here's how they remember him.
但他反对越南战争，并支持民权。而且这里有一点你可能猜不到。他非常出色。帕特里夏·加里和吉恩·加尔文都是辛辛那提的政治老手。以下是他们对他的回忆。
He was absolutely the most gifted, natural politician I ever saw. The grandmothers all loved him. The daughters all loved him. You know, the brothers and sisters-- everybody was a good friend of his. They were great. There was always that kind of a glamour around him, where he was clearly a golden boy.
他绝对是我见过最有天赋、最自然的政治家。祖母们都喜欢他，女儿们都喜欢他，你知道，兄弟姐妹们——每个人都是他的好朋友。他们太棒了。他身上总有一种魅力，显然是个金童。
I put Springer at the level of Ronald Reagan, Bobby Kennedy, Bill Clinton. He's that level.
我把斯普林格放在罗纳德·里根、鲍比·肯尼迪、比尔·克林顿的水平上。他是那个级别的。
And it's not just local Cincinnati people who feel this way about Springer. Mike Ford met Springer back in the '70s, but has moved up in politics and is today a Democratic political strategist at the national level.
而且不仅仅是辛辛那提当地人对斯普林格有这种感觉。迈克·福特在70年代就认识了斯普林格，但他后来在政界晋升，今天是一位国家级的民主党政治策略师。
I worked with Clinton, '90, '92. '88, Dukakis. '80, I worked for Kennedy. '76, I went through Birch Bayh, Mo Udall, and Jimmy Carter. He's the best I've ever seen, bar none.
我曾与克林顿合作过，90年、92年。88年为杜卡基斯工作，80年为肯尼迪工作。76年我经历过伯奇·贝赫、莫·尤达尔和吉米·卡特。他是我见过最好的，没有之一。
Jerry! Jerry! Jerry! Jerry! Jerry!
杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Hey, welcome to the show. How you doing? My guests today say they're coldhearted mistresses who are proud to be breaking up marriages. Please meet Holly. She says she does more than just babysit her friend's three kids. Holly, what is going on?
嘿，欢迎来到节目。你好吗？我今天的嘉宾说她们是冷酷的情妇，以破坏婚姻为荣。请认识一下霍莉。她说她做的不仅仅是替朋友看三个孩子。霍莉，发生了什么事？
I've been screwing my friend's husband.
我一直在和朋友的丈夫上床。
It's kind of a long drop from wanting to save the world to hosting TV shows with titles like, "I Have Sex with My Twin" and "I Want to Be a Teen Stripper." The story of Jerry Springer is the story of an act of transformation so complete and so total that most people don't even know what happened. It's really the story of two Jerry Springers-- one known only to a pocket of people in Southwest Ohio as the heir apparent to progressive politics in America, the other known the world over as the king of trash TV.
从想要拯救世界到主持电视节目，标题如《我和我的双胞胎发生性关系》和《我想成为青少年脱衣舞女》，这真是一个巨大的跌落。杰瑞·斯普林格的故事是一个极其完整和彻底的转变，大多数人甚至不知道发生了什么。这实际上是两个杰瑞·斯普林格的故事——一个只被俄亥俄州西南部的一小部分人知道，是美国进步政治的法定继承人；另一个则是全世界都知道的垃圾电视之王。
Go ahead. Tell her.
说吧。告诉她。
Theresa, I've been screwing your husband. And he loves having sex with this.
特蕾莎，我一直在和你的丈夫上床。而且他喜欢和我做爱。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
[BLEEPING]
[消音]
Jerry! Jerry! Jerry! Jerry!
杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！
Well, he was Kennedy-like, very bright.
嗯，他很像肯尼迪，非常聪明。
This is a comparison that comes up a lot when people talk about the other Jerry Springer. And it's no coincidence. The summer before Springer first ran for office in Cincinnati, he'd worked as a volunteer with Bobby Kennedy's presidential campaign. Here's Jene Galvin.
当人们谈论另一个杰瑞·斯普林格时，这种比较经常出现。这绝非巧合。在斯普林格第一次在辛辛那提竞选公职的前一个夏天，他曾担任鲍比·肯尼迪总统竞选活动的志愿者。这是吉恩·加尔文的说法。
When Jerry got to Cincinnati, he had a Boston/Harvard/Kennedy accent. He doesn't have it anymore. But when he got here, he had it. If you hear any old tape of him from that era, see any video clips, Jerry Springer came to town talking like Bobby Kennedy.
当杰瑞来到辛辛那提时，他有着波士顿/哈佛/肯尼迪的口音。他现在已经没有那种口音了。但他刚到这里时确实有。如果你听到任何他那个时代的旧录音，看到任何视频片段，杰瑞·斯普林格当时说话就像鲍比·肯尼迪。
My campaign is based upon the proposition that the answers to the problems which currently plague our cities, our towns, and our homes are not to be found in the decisions in Washington. They are instead to be found in the hearts, minds, and resources of our own people here at home.
我的竞选基于这样一个主张：目前困扰我们城市、城镇和家庭的问题的答案，在华盛顿的决策中是找不到的。相反，它们在此时此地我们自己人民的心灵、思想和资源中。
On old footage from this campaign, Springer looks even younger than 25. He looks like a kid in one of his father's suits, pretending to be Bobby Kennedy. But crowds loved him. He seemed like somebody reaching for something big, even when he's talking about business prosperity and the gross national product.
在这次竞选的旧镜头中，斯普林格看起来甚至不到25岁。他看起来像个穿着父亲西装的孩子，假装成鲍比·肯尼迪。但民众喜欢他。他看起来像个追求远大目标的人，即使当他在谈论商业繁荣和国民生产总值时也是如此。
The GNP by itself is no mark of our national achievement, for it includes smokestacks that pollute, drugs that destroy, and ambulances which clear our highways of human wreckage. It includes a mugger's knife, a rioter's bomb, and Oswald's rifle. But if the GNP tells us all this, there is much that it does not tell us. It says nothing of the health of our families, the quality of their education, or the joy of their play.
国民生产总值本身并不是我们国家成就的标志，因为它包括污染环境的烟囱、毁灭性的毒品以及将人类残骸从高速公路上清理走的救护车。它包括强盗的刀、暴徒的炸弹和奥斯瓦尔德的步枪。但是如果国民生产总值告诉我们这一切，还有很多它没有告诉我们。它对我们家庭的健康、教育的质量或他们游玩的快乐只字不提。
Springer was running in one of the whitest and most conservative parts of a very conservative city against a 10-year incumbent. And he lost that first race. It was the last time he would lose an election for the next decade. One year later, he ran for and was elected to the Cincinnati City Council. Tim Burke was his legislative aide on the council.
斯普林格是在一个非常保守的城市中最白人化、最保守的地区之一，与一位任职10年的现任议员竞争。他输掉了那场首次竞选。这是他接下来十年里最后一次竞选失败。一年后，他竞选并当选为辛辛那提市议会议员。蒂姆·伯克当时是他在市议会的立法助理。
Jerry could go into a VFW hall and talk about why he was opposed to the war in Vietnam. And that was not a popular thing to do. He wouldn't convince VFW folks, at least not the majority of them, that they should come out against the war in Vietnam. That wasn't in their nature. But he'd walk out of that room, and they'd like him.
杰瑞可以走进一家退伍军人协会（VFW）大厅，谈论他为何反对越南战争。那不是一件受欢迎的事。他无法说服退伍军人协会的人，至少无法说服大多数人，让他们站出来反对越南战争。那不是他们的本性。但他走出那个房间时，他们会喜欢他。
And this is the remarkable thing about Jerry Springer the politician.
这就是政治家杰瑞·斯普林格最了不起的地方。
Again, longtime friend Jene Galvin.
再次请出老朋友吉恩·加尔文。
He has connectability that transcends specific viewpoints of people. He'd get votes from West-siders saying, I don't agree with anything you say, but I just like your style. I like your guts.
他有一种超越特定人群观点的连接能力。他会从西区选民那里获得选票，他们会说，我不同意你说的一切，但我就是喜欢你的风格。我喜欢你的胆量。
The result of this was that on City Council, Springer had an uncanny ability to bring a marginal message without actually marginalizing himself. Again, here's Tim Burke, Springer's legislative aide.
结果是，在市议会，斯普林格有一种不可思议的能力，能提出边缘议题，却不会让自己被边缘化。再次请出斯普林格的立法助理蒂姆·伯克。
In 1971, when Jerry was elected to City Council, there was a proposal to build Riverfront Arena. And the proposal was to do it with public dollars. And the original vote on council as to how that was going to go was an 8 to 1 vote. Jerry was the only one who opposed it.
1971年，杰瑞当选市议会议员时，有一个修建河滨体育馆的提案。提案是打算用公共资金来做。市议会最初的投票结果是8比1。杰瑞是唯一反对的人。
Opposed doing it?
反对做这件事？
Opposed doing it with public dollars. The day of a critical vote, two members of council were away. And it needed seven votes in order to meet certain procedural requirements. Jerry refused to give them the procedural vote, which had been the tradition.
反对用公共资金做这件事。关键投票那天，两名议员不在。它需要7票才能符合某些程序要求。杰瑞拒绝给他们投票，尽管那一直是惯例。
You don't hold something up on a procedural vote. You're free to vote against it on the merits, but you don't hold it-- well, Jerry bucked tradition and then started just talking about why this was a bad thing to do, and we ought not to be publicly financing these things that ought to be supported by private business. And in the end, he captured the attention of the citizens of Cincinnati.
你不会在程序性投票上阻挠某事。你有权在实质性问题上投反对票，但你不会阻挠——嗯，杰瑞打破了传统，开始谈论为什么这是一件坏事，我们不应该用公共资金资助那些本应由私人企业支持的项目。最终，他抓住了辛辛那提市民的注意力。
They rallied to his side. The other politicians on council got that message. And Riverfront Coliseum was built with private dollars, with very little public subsidy involved. And you don't see that happening in stadiums and arenas today.
他们聚集在他身边。市议会的其他政治人物收到了这个信息。河滨体育馆最终由私人资金建造，几乎没有涉及公共补贴。今天你在体育场和竞技场建设中可看不到这种情况。
Oh, he really got you going, I'll tell you.
哦，他真的让你很激动，我跟你说。
Guy Guckenberger is a Republican and was one of Springer's council opponents on Riverfront Coliseum funding. He says it wasn't any fun being on the other side of an issue from Springer.
盖伊·格肯伯格是一名共和党人，也是斯普林格在河滨体育馆资金问题上的议会对手之一。他说站在斯普林格的对立面一点也不好玩。
I mean, he'd, you know, make a public appeal and state a public position for an issue. And you were either-- you either went with him or you were the bad guy. I mean, you didn't have any choice then.
我的意思是，他会公开呼吁并阐明一个公共立场。你要么跟随他，要么你就是坏人。那时你没得选。
In 1974, Springer got elected to a second term with more votes than anyone else on City Council. Six months later, he resigned in a scandal. An FBI investigation into an illegal massage parlor across the river in Kentucky revealed that he'd been a repeat customer. How did they know? He'd paid for a prostitute with a check. Tim Burke was his legislative aide at the time.
1974年，斯普林格以市议会最高票数当选连任。六个月后，他因丑闻辞职。联邦调查局对河对岸肯塔基州一家非法按摩院的调查显示，他是常客。他们怎么知道的？他用支票支付了嫖资。蒂姆·伯克当时是他的立法助理。
We went something like 10 days in a row with the headline story in the Cincinnati Enquirer. Jerry was going through all kinds of personal hell. So was his wife, obviously. So was his family, as he had to call them and explain to them what he had done, and what it was doing. And this was a young man with an absolutely terrific career ahead of him. And it looked like it had all been destroyed.
我们连续十天左右都在《辛辛那提调查者报》的头版。杰瑞经历了各种各样的个人地狱。他的妻子显然也是，他的家人也是，因为他必须打电话给他们，解释他做了什么，以及正在发生什么。这是一个有着绝对光明前途的年轻人，看起来这一切都被摧毁了。
And you personally, what were your thoughts?
而你个人，你的想法是什么？
Part of it was, what the hell were you doing? Why would you throw away this terrific political career you had in front of you for a few minutes?
一部分是，你到底在做什么？为什么为了几分钟而抛弃你面前这大好的政治前程？
At the time, it seemed that people weren't angry at the act as much as they were at the sheer stupidity of paying for it by check. But Springer was clearly shaken. The minute the facts became public, he resigned from council, so quickly, in fact, that his colleagues seemed a little shocked.
当时，人们似乎对这件事本身并不像对用支票支付这种愚蠢行为那么愤怒。但斯普林格显然受到了打击。事实一公开，他就辞去了议会职务，事实上辞职得如此之快，以至于他的同事们都感到有些震惊。
I think Jerry would tell the story that his initial thoughts were, I'm going to resign. I'm disgraced. I'm leaving town. I'm going to go start a new life someplace else.
我想杰瑞会说，他最初的想法是：我要辞职。我蒙羞了。我要离开这个城市。我要去别的地方开始新生活。
Within about 24 hours, he and his wife Micki and his other friends decided that wasn't the way to do it. And he held another press conference. And he just said, here's what happened. Here's what I did. I'm ashamed of it. I apologize. And just came absolutely-- and bared his soul to the Cincinnati public. And they rallied to him again. It was amazing.
在大约24小时内，他和他的妻子米奇以及其他朋友决定不该那样做。他举行了另一场新闻发布会，他只是说：事情就是这样。我做了什么。我对此感到羞耻。我道歉。他完全敞开了心扉，向辛辛那提公众坦白。他们再次支持他。这太令人惊奇了。
Some of the nuns out of the College of Mount St. Joseph started a thing where they were sending stones and little pebbles to members of Cincinnati City Council, trying to encourage them to reject Springer's resignation with the message, "He who is without sin should cast the first stone." It was just-- it was tremendous the way that people responded to him. And that was really what started his comeback.
圣约瑟夫山学院的一些修女开始了一项活动，她们开始向辛辛那提市议会议员寄送石块和小鹅卵石，试图鼓励他们拒绝斯普林格的辞职，并传达这样一个信息：“无罪的人才应投掷第一块石头。”人们对他的反应真是太惊人了。那实际上开启了他的回归。
After a few months, Springer took tentative steps to get back into public life and manages another run for city council. The Democratic Party wouldn't endorse him, but they did leave a spot open for him on the ballot. Jene Galvin went with him to campaign.
几个月后，斯普林格采取了初步措施回到公共生活中，并设法再次竞选市议会议员。民主党不会支持他，但确实在选票上为他留了一个位置。吉恩·加尔文陪他去竞选。
The St. Patrick's Day parade in Cincinnati at the time was huge, huge. Ran through the downtown streets. Thousands of people would come. You'd hope for great weather. And on this day, we had great weather, a tremendous crowd.
当时的辛辛那提圣帕特里克节游行规模非常大，非常大。它穿过市中心的街道。成千上万的人会来。你会祈祷天气好。那天我们天气很好，人群汹涌。
And as Jerry would come down through the crowd, they jeered him. They mocked him. And some of it didn't mean they wouldn't vote for him, but they mocked him.
当杰瑞穿过人群时，他们嘲笑他，戏弄他。其中一些并不意味着他们不会投票给他，但他们嘲弄他。
Hey, Jerry, you got a check on you? Hey, Jerry, you're really stupid, aren't you? Why did you write a check? Just yelling all this stuff.
嘿，杰瑞，你身上带支票了吗？嘿，杰瑞，你真的很蠢，不是吗？你为什么开支票？只是在喊这些话。
And he would just sit there and smile, and laugh, and take it. And, boy, my heart was breaking for my buddy up on that back seat because I'm down driving this car. He just took a beating.
他只会坐在那里，微笑，大笑，并承受这一切。天哪，看到我的好友坐在那辆车的后座，我的心都碎了，因为我在开车。他遭受了严厉的打击。
Still, the campaign worked. 18 months after resigning from City Council in disgrace and admitting publicly that he'd paid for a prostitute with a check, Jerry Springer was elected by the citizens of Cincinnati to a third term on City Council. Two years later, back on the Democratic ticket again, he was elected mayor, this time with the largest vote total in the city's history. It's not going too far to say that less than four years after being caught writing a check to a prostitute, Jerry Springer had become the most popular politician in Cincinnati ever, partly because he was able to mock his own stupidity. A rock and roll radio station convinced him to record a spoof commercial, a takeoff on a popular credit card ad at the time.
尽管如此，竞选奏效了。在辞去市议会议员职务并在耻辱中公开承认自己用支票支付嫖资18个月后，杰瑞·斯普林格再次被辛辛那提市民选为市议会议员。两年后，他再次回到民主党候选人名单上，当选为市长，这次是以该市历史上最高的总票数当选。可以说，在被发现用支票支付嫖资不到四年后，杰瑞·斯普林格就成了辛辛那提历史上最受欢迎的政治家，部分原因是由于他能够嘲笑自己的愚蠢。一家摇滚广播电台说服他录制了一则戏仿广告，改编自当时流行的信用卡广告。
Hi. Do you know me? My face is seen all over Cincinnati constantly. But when I travel, say, across state lines, people don't know the difference between Jerry Springer and Jerry Ford.
嘿。认识我吗？我的脸在辛辛那提到处可见。但当我出差时，比如说跨州旅行，人们分不清杰瑞·斯普林格和杰瑞·福特。
So that's why I carry this, the American Expense Card. It's the card that's good at thousands of clubs and motels across the river. I can even get instant, hassle-free check approval for quick, enjoyable entertainment that can't be beat, just like me.
这就是为什么我带着这个，美国消费卡。这张卡在河对岸的数千家俱乐部和汽车旅馆都好用。我甚至可以获得即时的、无障碍的支票批准，享受不可比拟的娱乐，就像我一样。
Most people, if they know the story at all, they know it wrong. They think Jerry Springer was mayor, there was a prostitution scandal, he resigned, and then had nothing else to do but become the Jerry Springer of The Jerry Springer Show. The truth is much stranger and more complicated. Jerry Springer became mayor after the prostitute. And The Jerry Springer Show was a full decade and a half after that, during which time Springer left politics more or less on his own terms and then rose again to the top of an entirely different field, television journalism.
大多数人，如果他们稍微了解这个故事，他们也了解错了。他们认为杰瑞·斯普林格当过市长，发生过卖淫丑闻，他辞职了，然后除了成为《杰瑞·斯普林格秀》的杰瑞·斯普林格之外没别的事可做了。事实要奇怪得多，也复杂得多。杰瑞·斯普林格是在嫖娼事件之后当上市长的。《杰瑞·斯普林格秀》那是整整15年之后的事了，在此期间，斯普林格或多或少按照自己的意愿离开了政治，然后又在另一个完全不同的领域——电视新闻中崛起。
The president of the local Teamsters Union in Cincinnati in Northern Kentucky is warning trucking companies to send trucks out in convoys after midnight on Monday.
辛辛那提北部肯塔基州当地卡车工会主席警告货运公司，周一午夜后让卡车排队出发。
This is Jerry Springer as he was known to Cincinnati throughout the '80s, local news anchor. Here's how he got there. In 1980, he stepped down as mayor to run for governor and lost in a tough three-way race. When it was over, he was out of money and jobless. So he accepted an offer to anchor the local news at Channel 5, the lowest-ranked local news program. In a fairly bold programming move, the station also let him end the broadcast with his own nightly commentaries, which were often of a liberal bent-- pro-union, anti-Reagan and Bush. He ended the broadcast each night with his signature phrase, "Take care of yourself and each other."
这就是辛辛那提在80年代所熟知的那个杰瑞·斯普林格，当地新闻主播。他就是这样走到那里的。1980年，他辞去市长职务竞选州长，但在一场艰难的三方竞争中落败。结束后，他没钱了，也没工作了。于是他接受了一份邀请，在排名最低的当地新闻节目——5频道担任主播。在一个相当大胆的节目举措中，电视台还让他用自己的每晚评论结束广播，这些评论往往具有自由倾向——支持工会，反对里根和布什。他每晚以招牌语结束广播：“照顾好你自己和彼此。”
Springer spent 10 years at Channel 5, during which he brought the nightly news from last to first in the ratings and earned 10 Emmy Awards. He attracted notice, including offers to host his own show. In September of 1991, the first Jerry Springer Show was taped. Soon afterwards, Jerry Springer left Cincinnati for good. His final commentary on the local news is legendary.
斯普林格在5频道工作了10年，期间他将每晚新闻的收视率从最后一名带到了第一名，并获得了10项艾美奖。他引起了注意，包括主持自己节目的邀约。1991年9月，第一期《杰瑞·斯普林格秀》录制完成。不久之后，杰瑞·斯普林格彻底离开了辛辛那提。他在当地新闻节目中的最后一次评论现在已成为传奇。
OK, bear with me. This will be a little tough. You should know, this isn't the first time I thought about leaving. I thought about it some 20 years ago when a check that would soon become part of Cincinnati folklore made me see life from the bottom.
好的，请耐心听我说。这将有点艰难。你应该知道，这不是我第一次想离开。大约20年前，一张后来成为辛辛那提民间传说的支票让我看到了生活的底谷，那时我就想过离开。
To be honest, a thought about ending it all crossed my mind. But a more reasonable alternative seemed to be, hey, how about just leaving town and running away, starting life over someplace else? You see, in political terms as well as human, here in Cincinnati I was dead.
老实说，结束一切的想法闪过我的脑海。但一个更合理的选择似乎是，嘿，逃离这个城镇，开始新生活怎么样？你看，在政治上以及人性上，在辛辛那提我已经是死人了。
But then in probably the luckiest decision I ever made, I decided, no, I'm staying put. I would withstand all the jokes, all the ridicule. I'd pretend it didn't hurt. And I would give every ounce of my being to Cincinnati. Why, in time, I was thinking, you'd have to like me, or if not like me at least respect me. And I'd run for council, even unendorsed. And I'd prove to you I could be the best public servant you ever had, or I'd die trying.
但后来，在可能是我做过的最幸运的决定中，我决定，不，我留下来。我会承受所有的笑话，所有的嘲笑。我会假装它不痛。我会把我全部的生命献给辛辛那提。为什么，我想，久而久之，你们不得不喜欢我，或者如果不是喜欢，至少尊重我。我会竞选议会，即使没有党派支持。我会向你们证明我可以成为你们有过的最好的公仆，否则我会死在努力的过程中。
Be it as a mayor, an anchor, or a commentator, whatever it took, I was determined to have you know that I was more than a check and a hooker on a one-night stand. But something happened along the way. Maybe it's God's way of teaching us. I don't know.
无论是作为市长、主播还是评论员，无论付出什么代价，我下定决心要让你们知道，我不只是一张支票和一夜情嫖客。但在这一路上发生了一些事情。也许这是上帝教导我们的方式。我不知道。
But you see, in trying to prove something to you, I learned something about me. I learned that I had fallen in love with you, with Cincinnati, with you who taught me more about life, and caring, and forgiving, and also, most importantly, giving, giving something back, which is part of the reason I have been-- excuse me-- so sad this week, why it's so hard to say goodbye. God bless you. And goodbye.
但你看，在试图向你们证明一些事情的过程中，我了解了一些关于我自己的事。我了解到我已经爱上了你们，爱上了辛辛那提，是你们教了我更多关于生活、关怀、宽恕，以及最重要的，给予，回馈一些东西，这也是为什么我本周如此——抱歉——如此悲伤，为什么很难说再见的原因。上帝保佑你们。再见。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Amy, you have a friend, Rusty. Let's now welcome him to the show. Here is Rusty.
艾米，你有个朋友叫拉斯蒂。现在让我们欢迎他来到节目。这是拉斯蒂。
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。哦，是的。
Go, Rusty!
去吧，拉斯蒂！
'Sup, tough guy? What's up, tough guy?
嘿，硬汉？怎么了，硬汉？
Uh-oh.
呃哦。
[THUD]
[沉闷的撞击声]
[AUDIENCE SCREAMING, EXCLAIMING]
[观众尖叫、惊呼]
Come on.
来吧。
[BLEEPING]
[消音]
It wasn't immediate, the switch from the nightly news to this. Originally, The Springer Show was meant to be the successor to Phil Donahue. And indeed, the first year's topics included homelessness and gun control. Springer booked political guests like Oliver North and Jesse Jackson. And the show seemed innocent and upstanding.
从每晚新闻到这个节目的转变并不是立即发生的。最初，《斯普林格秀》旨在成为菲尔·多纳休的接班人。事实上，第一年的主题包括无家可归和枪支管制。斯普林格预定了奥利弗·诺斯和杰西·杰克逊这样的政治嘉宾。节目看起来天真无邪且体面。
One early show bares the quaint title "Single People-- On the Outside Looking In." But the ratings tanked. A new producer was hired. And, well, you know the rest.
一个早期的节目有一个古怪的标题《单身人士——从外面往里看》。但收视率惨跌。雇了一位新制片人，嗯，你知道剩下的事了。
[AUDIENCE SHOUTING AND FIGHTING]
[观众大叫和打架声]
[BLEEPING]
[消音]
For those from Cincinnati, those who know the other Jerry Springer, watching the show can be bewildering. Again, here's Patricia Garry, who used to work with Jerry back in his City Council days.
对于那些辛辛那提人，那些了解另一个杰瑞·斯普林格的人来说，看这个节目可能会令人困惑。再次请出曾经在市议会时期与杰瑞共事的帕特里夏·加里。
Well, first off, that doesn't look like Jerry.
嗯，首先，那看起来不像杰瑞。
What is it about him, do you think, when you see-- what do you see when you're looking at him on the television?
当你看到电视上的他时，你觉得他身上有什么特质？你看到了什么？
I don't know. I mean, is he even in there? Where is Jerry? But he's still got that outward-- he can be happy with the microphones and smiling, and all that. And then he does that little pseudo-commentary at the end.
我不知道。我的意思是，他还在里面吗？杰瑞在哪里？但他仍然保持着那种外在——他可以在麦克风前表现得快乐，微笑，诸如此类。然后他在最后做那种伪评论。
Where's that positive energy? Where's that belief that he can make a difference? Where is that wanting to make a difference that's driving that? He was always shooting upward. I don't think that person-- I don't know if that person is around.
那种积极的能量在哪里？那种他能有所作为的信念在哪里？那种驱使他想有所作为的动力在哪里？他总是积极向上。我不认为那个人——我不知道那个人是否还在。
That's the thing that seems to me is that somebody with this gift clearly--
这对我来说似乎是一个有这种天赋的人明显——
It's a Greek tragedy, isn't it? It's really a Greek tragedy, yeah. Couldn't have written a better one, to end up being-- to end up being the joker instead of being the king.
这是一个希腊悲剧，不是吗？这确实是一个希腊悲剧，是的。写不出比这更好的剧本了，最后竟然成了小丑而不是国王。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm not conflicted because I'm not-- I know there's me, and then there's the show.
我不矛盾，因为我不——我知道有我，然后有节目。
Jerry Springer might be the only person intimately familiar with Jerry Springer, who claims to feel no ambivalence about the place Jerry Springer has ended up. I talked to him in his office before he taped his show. It's hard not to like him. He's engaging, funny. But there's a certain practiced quality to the way he answers questions about his career choices.
杰瑞·斯普林格可能是唯一一个极其熟悉杰瑞·斯普林格的人，他声称对杰瑞·斯普林格最终所处的位置毫无矛盾感。在录制节目之前，我在他的办公室和他谈过。很难不喜欢他。他风趣、有趣。但他回答关于职业选择的问题的方式有一种经过练习的特质。
You know, I create this persona for the show. And that's what it is. You know, I'm an act. It's like I'm in movies. Look, no one goes after some actor because, let's say, he played Hitler in the movies.
你知道，我为节目创造了这个角色。事实就是这样。你知道，我是在表演。就像我拍电影一样。你看，没人会去攻击某个演员，比方说，因为他在电影里演了希特勒。
I mean, I'm not saying anybody should have a-- yeah, have an issue with it at all. Here's a person who every stage of their professional career, it's been imbued with a sense of trying to make a difference until you get to The Springer Show.
我的意思是，我不是说有人应该对它有任何问题。这是一个在职业生涯的每个阶段都充满想有所作为的感觉的人，直到你到了《斯普林格秀》。
Well, we've certainly made a difference in television. I'm not sure people are happy about it. I try not to think about it too much.
嗯，我们当然在电视上有所作为了。我不确定人们是否为此感到高兴。我尽量不去想它。
Life is what it is. And you take what's handed, and you work as hard as you can, and hopefully you'll be successful. But I just don't spend too much time worrying about that. I mean, I do my show.
生活就是这样。你接受所发生的一切，尽可能努力工作，希望你会成功。但我就是不会花太多时间去担心那个。我的意思是，我做我的节目。
And, look, I've always said it's a stupid show. I've had a wonderful life because of it and all that, but I've never for a second thought that it's important. It's trivial. It's chewing gum. And I recognize that once you do something that's significant in life, all this other stuff is just a way to eat.
而且，看，我一直说这是一个愚蠢的节目。因为它是，我度过了美妙的一生，但我从来没有一秒钟认为它是重要的。它是琐碎的。它是口香糖。我承认，一旦你在生活中做了有意义的事情，所有这些其他东西都只是糊口的方式。
From talking to Springer and his friends, I think the best answer to the question, how did this idealistic, political guy end up in a job where he helps no one, is partly he stumbled into it and was surprised as anyone about how big it got. Once the show started what they euphemistically referred to as "targeting the youth market," its success was both instantaneous and breathtaking. Within the span of a couple of years, Springer went from being just another talk show host to a worldwide phenomenon. The Springer Show can be seen on televisions in over 40 countries worldwide, including Tunisia.
通过与斯普林格和他的朋友交谈，我认为对于“这个理想主义的政治人物怎么会落得在工作里帮助不到任何人”这个问题，最好的回答是：他部分是误打误撞进入了这个行当，并且和任何人一样对它的成功规模感到惊讶。一旦节目开始进行他们委婉地称为“针对青年市场”的尝试，它的成功既是瞬间的又是惊人的。在几年内，斯普林格就从一个普通的谈话节目主持人变成了一个全球现象。《斯普林格秀》可以在全球超过40个国家的电视上看到，包括突尼斯。
And when the show is named after you, you get a lot of the money. And the money really meant something to him. He'd come to this country when he was five, the child of Jewish refugees who escaped to America from Nazi Germany. But there is some evidence that Springer is more ambivalent about his current job than he's willing to let on to a reporter. About four or five years ago, he started making phone calls to his old friend Mike Ford, who ran several of Springer's political campaigns, just to chat about politics. The more notoriety the show attracted, the more popular it became, the more frequently, it seemed to Mike, Jerry would phone him.
当节目以你的名字命名时，你会得到很多钱。钱对他来说确实意味着什么。他五岁时来到这个国家，是逃离纳粹德国来到美国的犹太难民的孩子。但有一些证据表明，斯普林格对他目前的工作比他愿意向记者透露的要矛盾得多。大约四五年前，他开始给老朋友迈克·福特打电话，迈克曾管理过斯普林格的几次竞选活动，只是为了谈论政治。节目引来的名声越大，它就越受欢迎，迈克觉得杰瑞给他打电话的频率似乎就越高。
We talked, I would say, maybe once a month. And it was always almost getting back in. He would call me. And he would say, so what are we going to do? And I would say, well, I'm doing it. I don't know what you're going to do, but it's not happening on the show. And then we'd talk about options. And we looked at everything.
我们大约一个月谈一次。几乎每次都是关于重返政坛。他会给我打电话。他会说，我们要怎么做？而我会说，嗯，我正在做这件事。我不知道你要怎么做，但节目里不会发生这种情况。然后我们讨论选择。我们审视了一切。
I went down to Mississippi to look at running against Trent Lott. We looked in New Orleans. We looked everywhere, but especially in Ohio.
我去了密西西比州考虑竞选挑战特伦特·洛特。我们看了新奥尔良的情况。我们在各地都看了，但特别是在俄亥俄州。
And he was feeling it out for years. I mean, he was empty, OK? That's the issue here. The show does not make him happy. It didn't fill his needs as a person.
他多年来一直在试探。我的意思是，他是空虚的，好吗？这就是这里的问题。节目并没有让他快乐。它没有填补他作为个人的需求。
If you follow the news very closely, you may recall stories in early 2003 that Jerry Springer was considering a run for Senate in Ohio. Much of the national news reported this as a joke, a talk show fool trying to dress up as a statesman.
如果你非常密切地关注新闻，你可能还记得2003年初有关杰瑞·斯普林格考虑在俄亥俄州竞选参议员的新闻。大多数全国性新闻报道称这是一个笑话，一个谈话节目的傻瓜试图伪装成政治家。
But the small band of Jerry's friends from before knew the story was actually the opposite-- a former statesman was trying to shake off the costume of a talk show fool. What this meant for Jerry was going around the state and speaking in front of as many Democrats as he possibly could. Jene Galvin went with him.
但那一小群杰瑞以前的朋友知道事实正好相反——一位前政治家正试图摆脱谈话节目傻瓜的伪装。这对杰瑞来说意味着在全州奔走，尽可能多地在民主党人面前演讲。吉恩·加尔文陪着他。
People say, would you come down to Hawking College and speak? Yes. Will you come to the Mercer County Democratic Party dinner and speak? Yes. Will you come down to Athens County and help a young Ohio University woman running for city council win an election? Yes. He goes.
人们会说，你能来霍金学院演讲吗？可以。你会来默瑟县民主党晚宴演讲吗？会。你会来雅典县帮助一位正在竞选市议员的俄亥俄大学年轻女性赢得选举吗？可以。他都去了。
I introduced him to the State Democratic County Chairs Association back in January.
我在一月份向州民主党县主席协会介绍了杰瑞。
Again, Tim Burke.
再次请出蒂姆·伯克。
And as I introduced him, you could just see that there was a great deal of skepticism in that room. Because for the most part, the county chairs from around the state of Ohio only knew Jerry for this crazy television show he has.
当我介绍他时，你能看出房间里有很多怀疑。因为在很大程度上，俄亥俄州各地的县主席只知道杰瑞是因为他那个疯狂的电视节目。
Many of you know him only as a host of some goofy television show. I know him as somebody who cares deeply about people, about politics. I'm proud to introduce you to my longtime friend, Jerry Springer.
你们很多人只知道他是某个愚蠢电视节目的主持人。我知道他是一个真正关心人、关心政治的人。我很荣幸向你们介绍我的老朋友，杰瑞·斯普林格。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Thank you very much. May you never be on my show.
非常感谢。愿你永远别出现在我的节目里。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You could literally watch the audience change from skepticism to an audience that was laughing with Jerry.
你可以真切地看到观众从怀疑转变为与杰瑞一起大笑。
The tax cuts proposed by the president are obscene. What the hell is he giving someone like me a tax break for?
总统提议的减税政策是荒谬的。他为什么要给像我这样的人减税？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The argument for the tax package-- and you've heard it on the-- you hear it all the time. The argument for the tax package is to give people back their money so they'll spend it and will help the economy.
关于税收方案的论点——你一直都能听到。关于税收方案的论点是把钱还给人们，以便他们会消费，这将有助于经济。
Here's what's stupid. Rich people can already afford anything they want to buy. Do you think if I get a check back in the mail, suddenly I'm going to buy something?
这很愚蠢。富人已经买得起他们想买的任何东西。你以为如果我在邮件里收到支票，我突然就会去买东西吗？
If I want to buy something now, I'll go out and buy it. Don't give me the money. Take that money, and make sure that every citizen in the United States of America has health insurance. That's where you spend the money.
如果我现在想买什么，我会去买的。别把钱给我。拿那笔钱去确保美利坚合众国的每一位公民都有健康保险。那才是你应该花钱的地方。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
If we would get that message across so the citizens of Ohio-- I don't care how Republican your district looks-- they will say, aha, that relates to me. Now there's a reason to sign up and vote Democrat. We got to give them a reason. That's what we stand for.
如果我们能把这个信息传达给俄亥俄州的公民——我不在乎你的选区看起来有多共和党——他们会说，啊，那与我有关。现在有一个注册投票支持民主党的理由了。我们必须给他们一个理由。这就是我们的立场。
We are right on the issues. It drives me insane when I watch the news and I see this garbage. Look, I'm the king of garbage, so I know garbage.
我们在问题上是正确的。当我看到新闻，看到这些垃圾时，我简直要疯了。看，我是垃圾之王，所以我知道什么是垃圾。
And at the end of the speech, he had them all up on their feet. These are a bunch of hard-bitten politicians who have heard lots of political speeches in their lives, and he had them on their feet at the end of the speech. He turned the room just like that.
演讲结束时，他让所有人都站了起来。这是一群饱经风霜的政治家，他们一生听过很多政治演讲，演讲结束时他让他们站了起来。他就像那样扭转了整个房间的气氛。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
You don't have to be a political strategist, however, to design the attack ad against the Jerry Springer Senate campaign. He airs one himself, twice a day in most markets, for an hour each time. So along with the speeches and the candidate appearances, Mike Ford tried to research the question, could Jerry Springer the man get beyond Jerry Springer the show? Put another way, had Springer forever blown his chance to do the one thing he truly loved doing?
不过，你不需要成为政治策略师就能设计针对杰瑞·斯普林格参议院竞选的攻击性广告。他自己就在播出，大多数市场每天两次，每次一小时。所以除了演讲和候选人露面，迈克·福特试图研究一个问题：杰瑞·斯普林格这个人能超越杰瑞·斯普林格的节目吗？换句话说，斯普林格是否永远失去了他真正热爱的事情的机会？
We put together, more or less, focus groups. And we sat them in a room. And instead of asking them questions directly about Jerry, we decided what we should do is, in effect, run a campaign before their eyes that was completely honest about all the things he'd ever done wrong or were distasteful and then mixing them with a bio of the guy, and then letting him talk to camera about issues.
我们或多或少召集了焦点小组。我们让他们坐在房间里。与其直接问他们关于杰瑞的问题，我们决定要做的是，实际上是在他们眼前进行一场竞选，对所有他做错的或令人反感的事情完全诚实，然后将它们与那个人的传记混合起来，然后让他对着镜头谈论议题。
We had impressive voices reading mean, horrible, nasty editorials. They had clips from the show. They had headlines about bad things. They saw all the bad, but then they saw a lot of the good.
我们有令人印象深刻的声音朗读刻薄、可怕、肮脏的社论。他们有节目的片段。他们有关于坏事的头条新闻。他们看到了所有坏的一面，但随后他们看到了很多好的一面。
In every market, we started horribly. And every single one of them turned around, in every audience, in every market. And the key thing there was that information is received in inverse proportion to its predictability.
在每一个市场，我们的开局都很糟糕。但每一个小组，每一个市场，都发生了转变。关键在于，信息的接收与它的可预测性成反比。
So if you said Jerry Springer is dating a llama, they would go, yeah, yeah, I saw that in the Enquirer. But then you start to unroll this other stuff. And when he looked at camera, instead of talking about what's going on in the state and in the country, it was completely persuasive because it was all new.
所以如果你说杰瑞·斯普林格在和一只美洲驼约会，他们会说，是啊，是啊，我在《调查者报》上看到了。但随后你开始展开这些其他的东西。当他看着镜头时，而不是谈论州里和国家正在发生的事情，这是完全有说服力的，因为这一切都是新的。
But there was one other thing they told Mike Ford. All the people in all the focus groups said the only way they could vote for him was if he quit his show. The voters, it turns out, could get beyond Springer the show to Springer the man, as long as Springer the man did it first, which is what killed his exploratory bid in the end. He couldn't get out of his TV contract in time to start a Senate race. But he's still out there giving speeches. If you go to the website runjerryrun.com, you'll see five events with Ohio Democratic organizations scheduled next month alone.
但他们还告诉了迈克·福特另一件事。所有焦点小组中的所有人都说，他们投票给他的唯一方法是他辞掉他的节目。事实证明，选民可以超越斯普林格的节目看到斯普林格本人，只要斯普林格本人先这么做，这最终扼杀了他试探性的竞选。他无法及时摆脱他的电视合同来开始参议院竞选。但他仍然在外面发表演讲。如果你去网站 runjerryrun.com，你会看到仅下个月就安排了五场与俄亥俄州民主党组织举办的活动。
Springer has been thinking a lot about his message. He hits it in every speech he gives. And it goes something like this. We all believe, Republicans and Democrats alike, that the purpose of government is to provide protection. No one disputes that government should maintain a military or a police force, or try to stop terrorists. But Democrats believe that government should protect its citizens from another form of violence as well.
斯普林格一直在认真思考他的信息。他在他发表的每一场演讲中都强调了这一点。大致是这样的：我们所有人，共和党人和民主党人，都相信政府的目的是提供保护。没有人否认政府应该维持军队或警察部队，或者试图阻止恐怖分子。但民主党人认为，政府也应该保护其公民免受另一种形式的暴力。
The violence of a pink slip on a Friday afternoon that says, you've been laid off, and now you don't have enough money to take care of your family-- job insecurity, the inability to get health insurance, that you have to choose, should I take my medicine this month, or do I buy my kid a coat for the winter? So the Democratic Party exists in America today to provide protection for middle and low-income America, particularly against economic violence, as well as military violence.
周五下午那张粉色解雇通知单带来的暴力，它告诉你，你被解雇了，现在你没有足够的钱照顾你的家人——工作不安全感，无法获得健康保险，你不得不做出选择，我是这个月买药，还是给我的孩子买件冬天的外套？所以民主党今天在美国的存在就是为了保护美国中低收入阶层，特别是免受经济暴力，以及军事暴力的侵害。
Has doing the show for these last eight, 10 years, has it informed your political thinking in any way?
在过去的八到十年里做这个节目，它在任何方面影响了你的政治思想吗？
No, it's just confirmed it. I mean, any job I've ever had, it's been the same constituency. It's been middle and low-income people that need a voice, that need help, that need whatever. So even in my entertainment, that's my base.
没有，它只是证实了它。我的意思是，我做过的任何工作，选民都是一样的。都是需要声音、需要帮助、需要什么的低收入人群。所以即使在我的娱乐节目中，那也是我的基本盘。
In politics, it certainly was my base. When I practiced law, it was my base. I mean, this is who I am.
在政治上，这当然是我的基本盘。当我做律师时，这是我的基本盘。我的意思是，这就是我。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
54 years ago this week, I came to America. I was five years old. Most of my family had been killed in the Holocaust in the camps in Germany and Austria during World War II.
54年前的这一周，我来到了美国。我当时五岁。我的大部分家人在第二次世界大战期间在德国和奥地利的纳粹集中营中被杀害。
The speech that you're hearing now is one Springer delivered back in January of 2003 to a group of Ohio Democratic County chairs. There was no press there. And the only reason we have it on tape is because an audience member recorded the whole thing on a personal tape machine from his chair. Probably thought it would be a joke. But he was so moved by the speech that he took the tape and had it duplicated at his own expense. He sent it around to all the county chairmen around the state.
你现在听到的这个演讲是斯普林格在2003年1月对一群俄亥俄州民主党县主席发表的。当时没有媒体在场。我们有录音的唯一原因是，一位观众用个人录音机从他的座位上录下了整个过程。他可能认为这会是个笑话。但他被演讲深深打动，所以他拿着录音带，自费进行了复制。他把它寄给了全州所有的县主席。
The idea being, here's a guy with a message for us. In the speech, Springer gives his standard economic spiel and also condemns America's current foreign policy as arrogant and bullying. And then he ends with his own story of first coming to America with his refugee parents on a boat from Europe.
想法是，这是一个给我们带来信息的人。在演讲中，斯普林格发表了他的标准经济说辞，也谴责了美国目前的傲慢和霸凌的外交政策。然后他以自己和难民父母乘船从欧洲来到美国的真实故事结尾。
We came over on the Queen Mary, January 19 to January 24, a five-day voyage over to America in 1949. And when we arrived, my very first memory was my mom waking me up and saying, Jerald, we have to go up on the top deck there, one of the decks of the Queen Mary. And all I remember-- because the rest has been told to me. I was only five.
我们于1949年1月19日至1月24日乘坐玛丽皇后号来到美国，那是为期五天的航行。当我们到达时，我最初的记忆是我妈妈叫醒我，说，杰拉尔德，我们要去上面那层甲板，玛丽皇后号的甲板之一。剩下的我记得是因为别人告诉我的，我那时才五岁。
But I vividly remember everyone standing out on top of the ship on the deck there-- there were about 2,000 passengers on board-- packed together, packed together. And what I remember other than being freezing is that nobody said a word. It was absolute quiet. And we were passing the Statue of Liberty.
但我清楚地记得每个人站在船顶的甲板上——船上有大约2000名乘客——挤在一起，挤在一起。除了冷得要死之外，我记得的是没有人说一句话。绝对安静。我们正经过自由女神像。
And my mother told me later on as I got older-- because, obviously, I wouldn't remember exactly what I had said. But she remembers me asking her, what are we looking at? And what does it mean? And she said in German, [SPEAKING GERMAN], one day everything.
我长大后我母亲后来告诉我——因为，显然，我不记得确切地说过什么。但她记得我问她，我们在看什么？这意味着什么？她用德语说，[德语]，有一天一切。
The Statue of Liberty means everything. We take it for granted today. We take it for granted. Remember, the Statue of Liberty stands for what America is. We, as Democrats, have to remind ourselves and remind the country the great principles we stand for. This is a place of protection.
自由女神像意味着一切。我们今天认为它是理所当然的。我们认为它是理所当然的。记住，自由女神像代表了美国是什么。我们，作为民主党人，必须提醒自己并提醒国家我们所代表的伟大原则。这是一个提供保护的地方。
This is not a country of bullies. We are not an empire. We are the light. We are the Statue of Liberty. Thank you for having me.
这不是一个欺凌者的国家。我们不是帝国。我们是光明。我们是自由女神像。谢谢你们邀请我。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The elements aren't new-- the immigrant experience, help for working people, the Statue of Liberty. But the fact is somehow electrifying for the people in that hall and the people passing around this tape. Wouldn't it be funny if in the end what the world really needs is more Jerry Springer?
要素并不新鲜——移民经历、对劳动人民的帮助、自由女神像。但事实是，对于大厅里的人和传递这份录音带的人来说，这不知何故是令人振奋的。如果最后世界真正需要的是更多的杰瑞·斯普林格，那不是很有趣吗？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Alex Blumberg, he is one of the producers of our show. Springer, like I said earlier, died last week at the age of 79. He was on TV until 2021 and did a weekly podcast until just a few months ago. Since the story first aired, Mike Ford, who's the political advisor in Alex's story, has also died.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格，他是我们节目的制作人之一。正如我之前所说，斯普林格上周去世了，享年79岁。他一直在电视上工作到2021年，并且直到几个月前还制作每周播客。自故事首次播出以来，亚历克斯故事中的政治顾问迈克·福特也已经去世。
Coming up, so two women, an Orthodox Jew, and Donald Trump walk into a bar. Actually, they walk into the second half of our show. And that happens in just one minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
即将播出，所以两个女人、一个正统派犹太人和唐纳德·特朗普走进一家酒吧。实际上，他们走进我们节目的下半部分。那将在一分钟后，当我们的节目继续在芝加哥公共广播电台播出时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Stories of People Leaving the Fold," and like Jerry Springer, having one part of them that stays stuck back in the old days before they left.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“离开群体的故事”，像杰瑞·斯普林格一样，他们内心有一部分被困在离开之前的旧时光里。
We have arrived at Act Two of our show-- Act Two, God and Hockey. Shalom Auslander and his wife were raised in religious homes, but they were wobbling away from it, thinking of leaving the fold. But still, living in an Orthodox Jewish community in Teaneck, New Jersey, they were huge fans of the hockey team the New York Rangers. And in 1994, the Rangers had an incredible season-- beat the Islanders, beat the Devils in a seven-game double overtime win, went to the playoffs against Vancouver. And during one of these away games, fans could go, while the team was in Vancouver, for $5 and sit in Madison Square Garden and watch the game on the jumbotron with other fans.
我们已经进入了节目的第二幕——第二幕，上帝与曲棍球。沙洛姆·奥斯兰德和他的妻子在宗教家庭长大，但他们正在远离它，考虑离开群体。但仍然生活在新泽西州提内克的正统犹太社区的他们，是纽约游骑兵曲棍球队的超级粉丝。1994年，游骑兵队经历了一个不可思议的赛季——打败了岛民队，在七场双加时赛中打败了魔鬼队，进入了与温哥华的季后赛。在这些客场比赛中的一场，当球队在温哥华时，球迷们可以花5美元坐在麦迪逊广场花园，和其他球迷一起在大屏幕上观看比赛。
But the problem for this couple was the game was on a Saturday, and religious Jews don't drive on Saturdays. It's against the rules of their religion. Shalom and his wife really, really wanted to go.
但这对夫妇的问题是比赛是在周六，而虔诚的犹太人在周六是不开车的。这违反了他们宗教的规定。沙洛姆和他的妻子真的、真的很想去。
So this was push coming to shove in terms of the whole God existence thing. We kind of looked at each other. And I was all for going. I just said, to hell with it. My argument was if God got them in that position, and--
所以这是关于上帝是否存在的问题。我们互相看了看。我全力支持去。我只是说，去他的。我的理由是，如果上帝让他们处于那个位置，而且——
[CHUCKLES] God made the Rangers winners.
[轻笑]上帝让游骑兵队成为赢家。
Look, he brought over Messier from Canada. He brought over Kovalev from Russia. He really went out of his way to get these guys into this position to win. It's probably a mitzvah to go watch them, this commandment to go watch them.
看，他把梅西耶从加拿大带过来。他把科瓦列夫从俄罗斯带过来。他确实竭尽全力让这些人处于获胜的位置。去看他们可能是一种善行，一条去看他们的戒律。
What was her argument?
她的论点是什么？
Her argument was fear, terror, God revenge. So her feeling was, let's walk. It's about 14 miles from what we judged.
她的论点是恐惧、恐怖，上帝的报复。所以她的感觉是，让我们走着去。我们估计大约14英里。
Wait a second. You actually thought that if you drove instead of walked that God would actually make the team lose?
等一下。你真的认为如果你开车而不是走路，上帝真的会让球队输掉比赛吗？
I did.
是的，是的。嗯，我当然知道，如果它发生了，我脑子里肯定会有一个部分会说，哦，做得好，做得好。他们打了一整个赛季，然后你得去坐出租车，现在看看发生了什么。
That would be his revenge on you, really?
所以我们从新泽西走到曼哈顿，真的吗？
Yeah, yeah. Well, I certainly knew that if it did happen, there would be a part of my head that went, oh, nice going, nice going. They play all season, and then you've got to go get in a cab, and now look what happened.
是的，真的。
So let's walk from New Jersey into Manhattan, literally?
穿过大桥。
Yes, literally.
沿着提内克路，沿着4号公路的一侧走，那是八车道的超级公路，穿过乔治·华盛顿大桥，穿过高速公路，穿过哈林区，到达百老汇，然后走100个街区到麦迪逊广场花园。
Across the bridge.
所以我们去了。当我们前进时，它结果比我们想象的要长得多，特别是在我们身穿安息日最华丽的衣服时。那是很难穿的鞋子。但她的脚慢慢磨出了水泡。情况越来越糟，她抱怨得也越来越多。
Down Teaneck Road, walk along the side of Route 4, which is this eight-lane super slab highway, cross the George Washington Bridge, walk down the highway, cross through Harlem, hit Broadway, and then it's 100 blocks down to Madison Square Garden.
到了她脱掉鞋子走的地步。我不知道你们有多少人去过曼哈顿，但穿着袜子在曼哈顿街头走是一个巨大的承诺。你一定是非常痛苦。
So we go. And as we're heading along, it's turning out to be quite a longer walk than we thought it was, particularly in our Sabbath finest. And those are hard shoes. But her feet are slowly blistering. And it's just getting worse and worse, and she's complaining more and more.
所以当我们到达那里时，比赛的欣快感接管了一切。能在那里真是太好了。但之后我们并没有真正考虑上帝，直到游骑兵队输了。我想他们以4比1输了。这太荒谬了。
It's at the point where she's taking her shoes off and walking. And I don't know how many of you have been in Manhattan, but that's a huge commitment to walk down a Manhattan street in just your socks. You've got to be in a lot of pain.
比赛结束了，每个人都痛苦地开始离开。我们只是站在那里目瞪口呆。我的意思是，不仅我们现在讨厌游骑兵队，而且我们——在神学上，我们在螺旋式下降。就在最后一声蜂鸣器响起的那一刻，我妻子看着我说，我们本应该开车的。
So by the time we get there, the euphoria of the game took over. And it was just really great to be there. But we didn't really consider God much after that until the Rangers lost. I think they lost 4-1. It was ridiculous.
就是那种，好吧，如果这是他要玩的方式，如果这是他玩的那种游戏，那么我们就不玩了。我们离开了花园。我吃了一个路边摊热狗。我就想，从现在开始我绝对不吃犹太洁食了。
And the game just ended, and everyone just starts filing out miserably. And we're just standing there just dumbfounded. I mean, not only do we now hate the Rangers, but we're just-- theologically, we're spiraling. And the moment that final buzzer rang, my wife looked at me and said, we should have driven.
[轻笑] 受着吧。
It was just that kind of, all right, if this is the way he's going to play, if this is the kind of game He's playing, then we're not having any of it. And we left the Garden. I had a sidewalk dog. I was like, I'm strictly non-kosher from now on.
是的，你觉得怎么样？我在哪里可以买到 Slim Jim？
[CHUCKLES] Take that.
还有牛奶。
Yeah, how do you like that? Where can I get a Slim Jim around here?
是的，完全正确。
And a milk.
我从来没有想到与上帝有个人关系的一个弊端是，你可能会不断地对他怀恨在心。我以为上帝总是带来安慰什么的。他在需要的时候会在那里。我从来没有想到你可以因为这样的事情对他产生怨恨。
Yeah, exactly.
嗯，这取决于你在想象什么样的上帝。我来自一个正常、极其功能失调的家庭，有一个相当专横的父亲。所以作为孩子，你进入这些希伯来学校。你听到“我们在天上的父”，我会想，哦，上帝，别告诉我天上还有一个。他在家里已经够糟糕了。他在家里已经够糟糕了。
I never thought about this is the downside of having a personal relationship with God, is that you'd constantly be bearing a grudge. I thought it was all just like reassurance and stuff from God all the time. He's there in times of need. I never thought that you could actually just feel a grudge against him for something like this.
哇，太有趣了。当你这么说的时候，我意识到，我对上帝的形象正好——我一生中从来没有把它联系在一起——完全是我父亲的形象，但更大，也就是说，他通常不在身边。有时他会表现出兴趣。他是好意。但大多数时候他有点像，你自己看着办吧。
Well, it depends what kind of God you're picturing. I came from a normally, incredibly dysfunctional family with a pretty overbearing father. So as a kid, you go into these Hebrew schools. You're hearing, "Our father who art in heaven," and I'm going, oh, God, tell me there's not another one up in heaven. He's bad enough at home. He's bad enough at home.
是的。那不是我的。我希望那是我的。我的上帝在天上，穿着内裤，喝得半醉，喝着 Kedem 葡萄酒，等着对人大喊大叫。
Wow, it's so interesting. I realized as you said that, my image of God is exactly-- I've never put this together in my life-- is exactly my image of my father, but bigger, which is, he's usually not around. Sometimes he'll take an interest. He means well. But mostly he's kind of like, you're on your own.
[笑声]
Yeah. That wasn't mine. I wish that were mine. Mine was a God in heaven lumbering around in his underpants half drunk on Kedem wine, looking to yell at somebody.
所以我想象那家伙看着游骑兵队的比赛说，去你的，哥们。
[LAUGHTER]
是的。所以你和球队有了这一刻。这在那个星期之后真的有后果吗？
So I picture that guy watching the Ranger game going, to hell with you, buddy.
你知道，我认为它有助于加速下滑。我认为它是——在那之后的一周是我们第一次无视安息日的事实。我想我们当时伟大的上帝革命就是坐进车里去购物中心。那对我们来说是大的一次。安息日是大的。那是很难克服的一个。
Yeah. So you have this moment with the team. Does this actually have consequences past that week?
所以这发生在十年前。有没有时候你怀念宗教生活，拥有那种生活，拥有那种社区？有没有什么部分是你在这条路上错过的？
You know, I think it helped hasten the slide. I think it was-- the week after was the first time that we just ignored the fact that it was Sabbath. And I think our big God revolution at that point was to get in our car and go to a mall. And that was the big one for us. Sabbath was the big one. That's the hard one to get past.
没有，因为我放弃了它的实践。但很有趣。我的家人或来自那个社区的人或任何我一起上学的人看着我会说，哦，他完全没有宗教信仰，一点也不灵性。但事实是，我觉得自己是我认识的最虔诚的人，因为我还没有完全把那个上帝从我的脑子里赶出去。他还在那儿。他仍然发表评论。
So this happened a decade ago. Have there been times that you missed being religious, having that life, having that community? Is there some part of it that you've missed along the way?
房间后面总有一个大个子、满脸皱纹的老人的照片，摇着头说，你会为此付出代价的。所以我可以说我不相信它，但这不会把那个角色从我的生活中赶走。我不知道为什么我不能直接放弃它。我希望我能。
No, because I gave up the practice of it. But it's funny. My family or the people from that community or anybody I went to school with would look at me and say, oh, he's completely irreligious and not spiritual at all. But the truth is, I feel like the most religious person I know because I still haven't quite gotten that God out of my head. He's still there. He still makes comments.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。这个故事出现在他的回忆录《包皮的哀歌》中。他最近的作品是一本名为《母亲晚餐》的小说。
There's always the picture of a big, old, frowning man in the back of the room shaking his head, saying, you're going to pay for this. So I could say I don't believe in it, but that's not going to get that character out of my life. And I don't know why I can't just give it up. I wish I could.
第三幕，你想去头等舱吗？有时候，发生了你想远离且永远不想再想的事情，但你发现你做不到。例如，你与唐纳德·特朗普有过一段不可磨灭的经历。这就是记者 E·琼·卡罗尔所说的发生在她身上的事。过去两周，她一直在法庭上。她是这几周在纽约市发生的唐纳德·特朗普强奸审判中的原告。
Shalom Auslander. This story appears in his memoir, Foreskin's Lament. His most recent book is a novel called Mother for Dinner.
卡罗尔说，90年代，唐纳德·特朗普在波道夫·古德曼百货公司的试衣间里强奸了她。他说她在撒谎，她的案子是“彻头彻尾的骗局”、“一场恶作剧”。她因诽谤和殴打起诉他。她是多年来指控这位前总统性侵犯和骚扰的几十名女性之一。前总统否认了所有指控。
Act Three, Would You Like to Come Up to First Class? Sometimes, something happens to you that you'd like to walk away from and never think about again, but you find you can't. For instance, you had an indelible experience with Donald Trump. That's what the journalist E. Jean Carroll says happened to her. These last two weeks, she's been in court. She's the accuser in the rape trial of Donald Trump that's been happening in New York City.
这些故事被广泛报道，每个人都对它们非常习惯，以至于几年前，对卡罗尔来说，感觉在那个时候它们只是被忽略了，这在她看来不可思议。这些故事不知何故似乎并不重要，这让她很难受。所以她决定尝试做点什么。
Carroll says that back in the 1990s, Donald Trump raped her in a dressing room at the department store Bergdorf Goodman. He says she's lying, that her case is a, quote, "complete con job," "a hoax." She's suing him for defamation and for battery. She's one of dozens of women who've accused the former president of sexual assault and harassment over the years. The former president denies all their allegations.
她与其他指控总统的女性进行了多次交谈，并将它们发表在《大西洋月刊》的一系列报道中。她的想法是，大多数人对这些故事只有一个模糊的了解，对这些女性声称真正发生了什么并没有太多了解。她的想法是，通过深入挖掘故事的细节，她将把它们恢复到人类的尺度和完整的色彩。
These stories have been so widely covered, and everybody is so used to them that a few years back, to Carroll, it felt like at that point they were just being ignored, which seemed incredible to her. It killed her that these stories just somehow didn't seem to matter. And so she decided to try to do something about it.
她为我们改编了她当时写的一篇文章。我们最初在2020年播出了这个故事。这一篇是关于唐纳德·特朗普的指控者之一杰西卡·利兹，她实际上在这几周的 E·琼·卡罗尔审判中作证了。在我们开始之前，有一个关于内容的警告。这是一个关于据称性侵犯的坦率谈话。这是 E·琼·卡罗尔。
She had a bunch of conversations with other women who have accused the president, and she published them in a series of stories in The Atlantic. And her idea was, most people only have a vague sense of these stories and don't really have much of a sense of what these women say actually happened. And her thought that was that by diving into the details of the story, she would restore them to human size and full color.
让我来设定场景——盛夏的黄昏，杰西卡·利兹和我正在放下我们剩下的一点点伪装。杰西卡在她位于蓝岭山脉的优雅小屋里。我在阿巴拉契亚小径旁的小棚屋里。我们像两只老尖叫猫头鹰一样在 Zoom 上交流，发现我们有多少共同之处，其中包括我们对保罗·纽曼先生的热爱、我们的年龄和我们的身高。
She adapted one of the articles that she wrote back then for us. We first aired this back in 2020. This particular one is with one of Donald Trump's accusers named Jessica Leeds, who actually testified in E. Jean Carroll's trial these past few weeks. Warning about content before we start. This is a frank conversation about alleged sexual assault. Here's E. Jean Carroll.
你现在多高？
Let me set the scene-- midsummer twilight and Jessica Leeds and I are letting down what's left of our hair. Jessica's in her elegant crib in the Blue Ridge Mountains. I'm in my little shack just off the Appalachian Trail. And we're Zooming like two old screech owls, discovering how much we have in common, which includes our love for Mr. Paul Newman, our age, and our height.
嗯，我现在5英尺7英寸。在那个时候我曾是5英尺9英寸——我丢了2英寸。
How tall are you now?
我也是。我丢了2英寸。
Well I'm 5' 7" now. I was 5' 9" at the-- I've lost 2 inches.
我不知道它们去哪了，但我丢了它们。我喜欢个子高。当我工作时，我总是非常感激——
Me too. I've lost 2 inches.
是的，我也是。
I don't know where they've gone, but I've lost them. I love being tall. When I was working, I was always so thankful--
——我个子高。
Yeah, me too.
大约40年前，当杰西卡为一家向《华盛顿邮报》等出版物销售新闻纸的公司担任销售员时，她坐在飞机上唐纳德·特朗普旁边。让我说，如果你从未与一位银发、精致的78岁女性 Zoom，她描述被困在布兰尼夫航空公司的航班座位上，一位美国未来总统试图把他的嘴唇像一条6英尺2英寸的吸鱼一样贴在她身上是什么感觉，好吧，在我看来，你还没活过，更别提 Zoom 了。
--that I was tall.
但在我们登上那次航班之前，复习一下。杰西卡是2016年第一批公开指控特朗普性侵犯的女性之一。《纽约时报》的头版报道了这件事。
About 40 years ago, when Jessica was working as a salesperson for a company that sold newsprint to publications like The Washington Post, she sat down next to Donald Trump on an airplane. Let me just say that if you have never Zoomed with a silver-haired, soigné 78-year-old woman who describes what it's like being strapped in a seat on a Braniff Airlines flight with a future president of the United States trying to fasten his lips on her like a 6' 2" suckfish, well, in my opinion, you have not lived, let alone Zoomed at all.
我知道如果故事真的引起任何注意，特朗普说的第一件事就是我长得不够漂亮。
But before we board that flight, a refresher. Jessica was one of the first women to publicly accuse Trump of sexual assault in 2016. It was on the front page of The New York Times.
对。
I knew if the story did get any attention that the first thing Trump would say is that I wasn't pretty enough.
我本能地知道他会这么说。
Right.
杰西卡是怎么知道的？因为杰西卡是一个老蝙蝠。老蝙蝠是最好的，甚至比尖叫猫头鹰更好。我自己也是一只老蝙蝠。我们老蝙蝠不会自欺欺人。事实上，在《纽约时报》发表关于杰西卡在1980年那架飞机上发生的事情后的第二天，特朗普在一次集会上对她的指控大吵大闹。
I knew instinctively that that's what he was going to say.
(嘲弄地) 哦，我在1980年和唐纳德·特朗普在一起。我当时和他在飞机上。他在飞机上想对我下手。是的，我要去下手——相信我，她不会是我的第一选择，我可以告诉你。
How did Jessica know? Because Jessica is an old bat. Old bats are the best, even better than screech owls. I'm an old bat myself. We old bats don't kid ourselves. And in fact, one day after The New York Times published a story about what happened to Jessica on that plane in 1980, Trump yammered about her accusations at a rally.
[观众笑声和欢呼声]
(MOCKINGLY) Oh, I was with Donald Trump in 1980. I was sitting with him on an airplane. And he went after me on the plane. Yeah, I'm going to go after-- believe me, she would not be my first choice, that I can tell you.
你不知道。那不会是我的第一选择。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING AND CHEERING]
我告诉杰西卡同样的事情也发生在我身上。
You don't know. That would not be my first choice.
我也知道它要来了。我当然知道。然后他对我说了同样的话——她不是我的类型。因为他们发我的照片时我75岁。这不公平。如果他们发的是我当年的样子，你和我因为我们是年长的女性而遭受了大量的狗屎。
I told Jessica the same thing happened to me.
为了杰西卡·利兹和全世界所有老蝙蝠的荣誉，杰西卡现在是个美女，40年前她登上那架去纽约的航班时也是个美女。正如她所记得的，那是一次布兰尼夫航班。布兰尼夫是时髦的航空公司。她的座位会是全纹皮革。她的空姐会穿着 Halston。她的飞机，会被涂成珀尔修斯绿、水星蓝或闪亮勃艮第酒红。
I knew it was coming too. I knew it, of course. And then he said it about me-- she's not my type. Because they're running pictures of me when I'm 75 years old. And it's not fair. If they had run pictures of me as I looked, you and I caught tons of shit because we're older women.
那你穿的是什么？你记得你登上那架飞机时吗？
For the honor of Jessica Leeds and old bats everywhere, Jessica is a beauty now, and she was a beauty 40 years ago when she got on that flight to New York. And as she remembers it, it was a Braniff flight. Braniff was the chic airline. Her seat would have been full grain leather. Her flight attendant would have been clad in Halston. And her plane, it would have been painted in Perseus Green, Mercury Blue, or Sparkling Burgundy.
是的。我穿着我最好的西装。那是棕色的粗呢。哦，我爱那套西装。它是夹克和裙子。那是一套很棒的行头。真的。不过那天之后我再也没穿过它。我把它留了一段时间，但我再也没穿过它。
And so what were you wearing? Do you remember when you got on that plane?
我完全明白她的意思。我和我在波道夫穿的那件裙子也是一样。
Yep. I had my best suit. It was a brown tweed. Oh, I loved that suit. And it was a jacket and a skirt. It was a fabulous outfit. It really was. I never wore it again after that day, though. I hung on to it for quite a while, but I never wore it again.
我不想扔掉它，因为它是一件漂亮的唐娜·卡伦。我永远不会扔掉它。但我不能穿上它，因为发生了坏事。
I know exactly what she means. It was the same for me with the dress I had on at Bergdorf's.
是的，完全正确。
I didn't want to throw it away because it was a beautiful Donna Karan. I would never throw it away. But I couldn't put it on because bad things happened.
好的，那不是很有趣吗？我们有很多共同点。好的。所以你——现在，告诉我发生了什么。你上了飞机。
Yeah, exactly.
我上了飞机。我坐在后面。我记得看着空姐走过过道。她看见了我，她说，你想去头等舱吗？我们有空间。
OK, so isn't that interesting? We have so much in common. All right. So you were-- now, tell me what happened. You get on the plane.
我从来没想过不说是的。我收拾好钱包，去了头等舱。那以前也发生过。
I get on the plane. I was sitting in the back. And I remember watching the stewardess come walking down the aisle. And she saw me, and she said, would you like to come up to first class? We have space.
是的，我也发生过。
It never occurred to me not to say yes. And I gathered my purse, and I went up to first class. That had had happened before.
是的。我接受了这样一个事实，即那是给头等舱大人物的娱乐节目。
Yeah, it's happened to me too.
现在，我不确定人们是否明白我们在说什么，但这就是他们所做的。他们选择了最好看、最时髦的人，把他们放进头等舱。
Yeah. I kind of accepted the fact that it was entertainment for the big honchos up in first class.
那是对的。
Now, I don't understand if people understand what we're talking about, but that's what they did. They chose the best-looking, best-dressed people and put them up in first.
我们在谈论的是事情过去的样子——买票、穿上我们最好的衣服、跳上鸡尾酒会、前往纽约、芝加哥、迈阿密或任何爵士城市，美国。除非有非常富有或非常漂亮的人在场，否则这个派对缺乏活力。头等舱的男士会在登机前打量女乘客，并与值机人员进行简短的会议。或者，一个乐于助人的空姐会简单地站在过道里，挥手让人们离开，并重新安排座位图，以便一个非常高的家伙，例如，有着像涂了油的毛毡一样黑发的家伙，可以坐在我旁边，这就是我告诉杰西卡的，在去洛杉矶的喷气式飞机上发生的事情。
That's right.
飞机起飞后，饭后，那家伙给我看了他私人飞机的照片。然后他给我看了一张他劳斯莱斯的照片。然后他给我看了他的勃起。
What we're talking about is how things used to be-- buying a ticket, putting on our best clothes, hopping on a cocktail party, heading for New York, or Chicago, or Miami, or any jazzy city, USA. And this party lacked zip unless somebody very rich or very pretty was present. Men in first class would size up the female passengers before boarding and hold a brief conference with the check-in crew. Or alternately, a helpful flight attendant would simply stand in the aisle, waving people away and rearranging the seating chart so that an extremely tall chap, for instance, with black hair like greased felt could have the spot by me, which is what I told Jessica had happened on a jumbo jet to LA.
我从来没想过给任何人打电话说什么。我们长大后期望男人对我们调情——我并不惊讶。我期望男人这样做。
After the plane took off, following the meal, the chap shows me a photo of his private plane. Then he shows me a photo of his Rolls-Royce. Then he shows me his erection.
杰西卡，你和我出生在第二次世界大战期间。我们没有举报。我们期望它。然后我们笑了。你笑了吗？
It would never have occurred to me to call anybody and say anything. We grew up expecting men to make a pass at-- I was not surprised. I expected it from men.
但你知道，我们错了。我们错了。我们应该像现在这样大声说出来。
Jessica, you and I were born during the Second World War. We did not report. We expected it. And we laughed.
嗯，我们非常感激，虽然，有——
But, you know, we were wrong. We were wrong. We should have spoken up like they're doing now.
哦，我知道，有这份该死的工作。
Well, we were so thankful, though, to have--
是的。哦，绝对。
Oh, I know, to have the fucking job.
哦，我的上帝。
Yeah. Oh, absolutely.
空姐陪杰西卡到飞机前部。她坐在唐纳德·特朗普旁边的过道座位上。
Oh, my lord.
据我记得，他自我介绍了。这个名字对我毫无意义。
The flight attendant escorts Jessica to the front of the plane. She sits down in the aisle seat beside Donald Trump.
那不会有意义。那是1979年，1980年。杰西卡不是纽约本地人。她还不知道纽约社会的各个层面、等级、领域，那是特朗普，一个来自皇后区的年轻老鼠，正在咀嚼穿过的。
As I recall, he introduced himself. The name meant nothing to me.
他在1980年长得很帅。你同意吗？
It wouldn't have. This was 1979, 1980. Jessica wasn't a native New Yorker. And she was not yet aware of all the levels, the ranks, the spheres of New York society that Trump, a young rat out of Queens, was chewing his way through.
嗯——
He was very good looking in 1980. Do you agree?
我在1996年发现他很有吸引力。他长得很漂亮。
Well--
是的，我想。
I found him very attractive in 1996. He was very pretty.
他并不丑。
Yeah, I guess.
我记得——我不记得我的反应了。我刚坐下时他表现得完全合理。我的意思是，他是一个金发、个子高、体型适中的男人，诸如此类。但我不记得被他的外表所折服或者——
He was not ugly.
他问过你的情况吗？
I can remember-- I don't remember my reaction. He was perfectly reasonable when I first sat down. I mean, he was blonde, tall, good-sized man, that sort of stuff. But I don't remember being overwhelmed by his looks or--
我们谈论了什么？我们谈论了他。我记得我们起飞了，他们提供了这顿美妙的饭菜。然后他们过来，把一切都收走了。在很短的时间内，突然间他就像一张湿毯子一样贴在我身上。
Did he ask you about yourself?
他先试着吻你了吗？
What did we talk about? We talked about him. I remember we took off, and they served this wonderful meal. And then they came, and they picked up everything. And within a short amount of time, all of a sudden he's on me like a wet blanket.
是的，是的。
Did he try to kiss you first?
她带着反感的畏缩从屏幕上移开。
Yes, yes.
那真是太震惊了。就像突然之间，他贴在我身上。
She glances away from the screen with a revolted wince.
杰西卡很有淑女风范。因此，请允许我，因为我有过特朗普的经验，用纯正的英语说我认为特朗普即将要做什么。我相信他会直奔胯下，就像他在《走进好莱坞》录音带上吹嘘的那样，这个今天声称从未在没有同意的情况下亲吻或摸过女人的男人。
It was such a shock. It was like all of a sudden, he's like on me.
就像他有四只额外的手一样，因为他在抓我的乳房。他在试图吻我。我在试图把他的手从我身上拿开。这场挣扎持续了一会儿。然后，当他开始把手伸进我的裙子时，我获得了一阵力量，设法扭动身体从座位上出来。
Jessica is ladylike. Therefore, allow me, for I have experience with Trump, to say in plain English what I believe Trump is about to do. I believe he will go straight for the crotch, just like he brags on the Access Hollywood tape, this man who today claims that he has never kissed or groped a woman without consent.
杰西卡抓起她的钱包，冲向飞机后部。
It's like he's got four extra hands because he's grabbing my breasts. He's trying to kiss me. I'm trying to get his hands off of me. And this struggle went on for a little while. And then it's when he started to put his hand up my skirt that I got a jolt of strength and managed to wiggle myself out of the seat.
等等，他到底有没有摸到你的内裤？
Jessica grabs her purse and storms to the back of the plane.
没有，没有。
Now, wait, so did he make it all the way to your panties or not?
因为你到那时已经开始站起来了，对吧？
No, no.
对。
Because you had, by that time, started to stand up, right?
还有别人吗？
Right.
是的，有个家伙坐在过道对面，他的眼睛大约像碟子那么大。我一直在想，你为什么不说什么？或者空姐在这整件事中在哪里？为什么没有人来救我？那时我意识到只有我才能救我自己。所以那就是我——
Was there anybody else?
好吧，我很高兴你想到——看，有些女性在这种情况下会冻住。
Yeah, there was the guy across the aisle whose eyes were about the size of a saucer. And I kept thinking, why don't you say something? Or where is the stewardess on this whole thing? Why doesn't somebody come and rescue me? And that's when I realized there's only me that was going to rescue me. So that's when I--
是的，是的，我知道。
Well, I'm glad you thought of-- see, some women freeze in this situation.
你没有冻住。
Yes, yes, I know.
不，不，但我当然没说什么。
You didn't freeze.
我也没说什么。我没尖叫。我没做——我笑了。你笑了吗？
No, no, but I certainly didn't say anything.
是的。不，我不记得笑了。不。我认真对待了。我的意思是，我——这是一次真正的身体攻击。而且——
I didn't say anything either. I didn't scream. I didn't do-- I laughed. Did you laugh?
哦，我知道这是一次攻击，一次骚扰。
Yeah. No, I don't recall laughing. No. I took it seriously. I mean, I-- this was a real physical attack. And--
是的。
Oh, I know it's an attack, an assault.
虽然我们谈论特朗普摸女人，但大多数人并不了解特朗普到底有多无耻，因为没人知道“摸”是什么意思。这也是我想和特朗普指控者交谈的原因之一。谁知道特朗普到底在做什么，或者他在女性身体的哪个部位做这件事？
Yeah.
其中一位特朗普的指控者描述了特朗普把手伸进她的裙子并放在她的外阴上。她用了简单的英语。她说就像挤压，一种挤压。她用手做了个动作，就像挤压橡皮鸭一样。那才是摸。那么特朗普为什么要这样做？杰西卡和我都在思考。
Although we talk about Trump groping women, most people don't understand how brazen Trump really is because no one knows what groping means. It's one of the reasons I wanted to talk to the Trump accusers. Who knows what the heck Trump is actually doing or on what part of the female body he is doing it?
让我们尝试弄清楚这一点。主要问题是，他知道他在飞机上不可能和你发生性关系。他知道这一点。他为什么要这样做？他以为他会得到什么？那是性的吗？你让他兴奋到他无法忍受了吗？那是什么？
One of Trump's accusers described for me Trump putting his hand up her skirt and onto her vulva. And she used the plain English. It was like a squish, she said, a squeeze. And she made a motion with her hand like squeezing a rubber duck. That is groping. So why does Trump do it? Jessica and I ponder.
嗯，就我个人而言，我不能——我觉得他很无聊。
Let's try to figure this out. The main question is, he knows he's not going to be able to have intercourse with you on the plane. He knows this. Why does he do this? What did he think he was going to gain? Was it sexual? Were you turning him on to such an extent that he couldn't stand it? What was it?
哦。
Well, personally, I can't-- I thought he was bored.
没什么事发生，所以让我们在这里抓个小猫。
Oh.
这对我来说真是个洞察。真是个洞察。明白了。
Nothing happening, so let's grab a little pussy here.
但这与他的好莱坞录音带相符。
This is such an insight to me. This is such an insight. Got it.
而且他没有注意力持续时间。
But it goes along with his Hollywood tape.
不，不。
And he has no attention span.
他事先在读什么吗？他有一本书吗？
No, no.
不，不。
Was he reading at all beforehand? Did he have a book?
报纸？
No, no.
不。
Newspaper?
谁会在1980年不带一堆杂志、报纸或《华尔街日报》上飞机？
No.
完全正确。
Who'd get on a plane in 1980 without a ton of magazines, newspapers, or The Wall Street Journal?
而且他没什么可读的？
Exactly.
不。
And he had nothing to read?
你以为他很无聊。那是一个我认为——它真的把它带回家了。因为有些人声称他是为了权力才这么做的。我不认为它与权力有任何关系。
No.
嗯，可能是。但我真的只是把它归咎于他很无聊。
You thought he was bored. That is an insight that I think-- it really sends it home. Because some people have claimed he does it for power. I don't think it has anything to do with power.
所以特朗普抓住一个女人，然后抓住下一个女人，再下一个。很快，我们开始认为特朗普抓女人是正常的。然后特朗普抓女人变得如此正常，以至于很无聊。
Well, it could be. But I really just chalked it off to him being bored.
这是旧新闻，他做了很多事。
So Trump grabs one woman, then he grabs the next woman, and the next woman. And pretty soon, we start thinking Trump grabbing women is normal. Then Trump grabbing women becomes so normal, it's boring.
但杰西卡，这不是旧新闻。我们是最新的事情。我们试图警告人们。我们试图警告美国这就是他。所以现在我们似乎被遗忘了。我们被推到——嗯，我们被忽略了。这让我发疯。这就是为什么我们要这样做。
It is old news, and there's so much that he's done.
像杰西卡和我这样的女人，我们永远不会忘记。
But Jessica, it's not old news. We're the most current thing. We tried to warn people. We tried to warn America this is who he was. And so now we seem to have been forgotten. We've been pushed-- well, we've been ignored. And this drives me crazy. This is why we're doing this.
在那个时候到2015年他再次出现之间，你多久想一次这件事？
Women like Jessica and I, we'll never forget.
如果不是因为在萨克斯第五大道的晚会，我可能不会在脑子里记得那么深。
How often did you think about this between then and 2015 when he came to the fore again?
萨克斯第五大道的晚会。那是在飞行一年或两年后。它是为纽约人道协会和其他一些慈善机构举办的募捐活动。杰西卡是人道协会主席的助理，负责分发表格。
I probably would not have had it so emblazoned in my mind if it hadn't been for the gala at Saks Fifth Avenue.
我穿了这件很棒的裙子。
The gala at Saks Fifth Avenue. This is a year or two after the flight. And it's a benefit for the Humane Society of New York and a few other charities. Jessica is the assistant to the president of the Humane Society and is handing out table assignments.
哦，是什么？让我听听。
I had this fabulous dress.
玛丽·麦克法登——
Oh, what was it? Let me hear.
哦，我喜欢玛丽·麦克法登。
Mary McFadden--
——百褶的，这所有的小百褶在出租车黄色的颜色里。我出现在萨克斯。我穿上了这件很棒的裙子。我在做我的事情。我遇到了杰弗里·比恩。我遇到了比尔·布拉斯。我为这个派对遇到了所有这些设计师。事实上，玛丽·麦克法登过来看着我，说，那是我的裙子。我说，是的，是你的。所以那真是一个美妙的夜晚。
Oh, I love Mary McFadden.
然后特朗普和他的妻子伊凡娜走了过来。她怀孕了，怀得很重。当我递给他桌位分配时，他看着我。我看着他，心想，你就是飞机上那个混蛋。我记得你。
--pleated, all these little pleats in a taxicab yellow. And I show up at Saks. And I've got this great dress on. And I'm doing my thing. And I'm meeting Geoffrey Beene. I'm meeting Bill Blass. I'm meeting all of these designers for this party. And in fact, Mary McFadden came up and looked at me, and said, that's my dress. And I said, yes, it is. So it was really a fabulous evening.
美国未来总统也记得杰西卡。
And then Trump with his wife Ivana came up. She was pregnant, very pregnant. And he looked at me when I handed him his table assignment. And I'm looking at him, thinking, you're the asshole from the airplane. I remember you.
他看着我，他说，“我记得你。你就是飞机上那个婊子。”
The future president of the United States remembers Jessica too.
E·琼·卡罗尔是一位记者，也是回忆录《我们为什么要男人？》的作者。她与指控唐纳德·特朗普性侵犯的女性的系列谈话在 atlantic.com 网站上。它被称为，“我非常猛烈地对待她”。她的故事是由苏珊·伯顿为我们的节目制作的。
And he looked at me, and he said, "I remember you. You're the cunt from the airplane."
我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我自己与黛安·库克、简·玛丽、斯塔利·凯恩和莎拉·凯尼格共同制作。今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。马特·蒂尔尼、斯托·尼尔森和阿拉·穆斯塔法的重播制作。今天特别感谢格雷格·弗兰纳里、约翰·基斯韦特、里克·彭德、乔·莫斯、亚当·罗森伯格、莎莉·福特、比尔·伍德、罗宾·伍德、斯科特·甘弗和辛辛那提历史协会。
E. Jean Carroll is a journalist and the author of the memoir What Do We Need Men For? Her series of conversations with women who accused Donald Trump of sexual assault is at the atlantic.com website. It's called, "I Moved on Her Very Heavily." Her story was produced for our show by Susan Burton.
《美国生活》由 PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生，他提醒你——
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Diane Cook, Jane Marie, Starlee Kine, and Sarah Koenig. Senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Production on the rerun from Matt Tierney, Stowe Nelson, and Alaa Mostafa. Special thanks today to Greg Flannery, John Kieswetter, Rick Pender, Joe Moss, Adam Rosenberg, Sally Ford, Bill Wood, Robin Wood, Scott Gamfer and the Cincinnati Historical Society.
直到下次，照顾好你自己和彼此。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia, who reminds you--
说得好。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
Until next time, take care of yourself and each other.
下次见，请照顾好自己和彼此。
Well said. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
说得好。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周同一时间，将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。